fresh back from
calling the game of monday night
football on westwood one is my buddy
from nfl network the nfl media group his
uh life story is going to be on the
silver screen coming up uh next month as
well and he is a hall of fame friend in
person calling calling into the rich
eisenhower kurt warner how are you kurt
i'm doing well i got up early and uh
just got back to phoenix but uh what
crazy game last night well i mean i'll
give you the floor because um you you
can already hear the uh rams aren't who
we thought they were
conversation after the titans and now
the 49ers have beaten them resoundingly
uh in back-to-back nationally televised
games so are the rams in trouble from
what you're seeing sure
i'm not going to say in trouble because
i think we've seen over the last couple
weeks
you know this whole league is up and
down i mean everybody that we think is
really good
has lost over the last couple weeks and
so i think we could say that same thing
about every single team well maybe
they're not who we thought they were um
mine right now is we don't necessarily
have
any great teams and there's a lot of
parody and you're going to see
um this whole thing shake up even more
over the last seven eight weeks of the
season um and i don't know how it's
going to finish you know with the rams i
just look at it and say
on paper they look really really good
but a lot of things have to come
together for the chemistry part of it
you know you think about robert woods i
just think about he's kind of the heart
and soul of that team the way he plays
the grit by which he plays the different
things that they ask him to do
you know that i think in our minds we
say oh well they have obj now and so obj
just going to step in and take that
place and they're going to be just fine
and those are the kind of things you
have to wonder about
um as they're trying to build this thing
and put a lot of new pieces together in
a short period of time
can they get there can the chemistry get
there to the point where
everything that we see on paper
plays out on the field between the lines
and they get all that unbelievable
collection of talent they get all of
that talent to come together and and
play as one and now they're maybe the
special team that that we think they
have the capability to be well i mean i
i i led the show curt by saying that the
bye week is perfectly timed for the rams
perfectly timed because stafford said he
could use a weak arrest with his back
and you know odell can get somewhat up
to speed obviously he's not going to
play the the robert woods role but he is
going to pick up slack in terms of
targets
um and and then von miller can get up to
speed and get healthy and
then they could just take a beat bury
the last two weeks and try and finish up
strong
but that said um
what do you see when you when you look
at stafford is is he hurt or or does
does he have uh a big game problem what
do you think
when you look at that
when i watch him i don't
see anything physically it says to me
you know that he's laboring or not doing
some things
that you would expect him to do or that
you've seen him do
um
you know i do think there seems to be
some continuity problems with
other guys besides um
besides cooper cup i mean for whatever
reason cooper cup and him are on the
same page and they look great together
but everybody else uh seems to be off a
little bit you know
different pieces kind of in there um
they're just not hitting on all
cylinders
from that standpoint and yeah i mean i
think there's always going to be the
question with matthew stafford just
because he's never been in the big game
um
you know and we can point our finger at
a lot of different things with detroit
of course
but you know the expectations are high
um on what people want from him and
expect from him because of all the
talent and now all the talent around him
um and we're gonna see how he plays
in the big moment in the big game
because you know as well as i do there's
there's a lot of really good players in
this league
that aren't great in that moment
and matthew shaffer is going to get an
opportunity to prove to us uh you know
what what he is as a player
at some point here and uh i think we're
all waiting to see we're all hoping that
um it was a detroit issue and not a
matthew stafford issue
as we move forward and one thing i was
saying on the broadcast last night rich
is that i sometimes feel like we're at a
point in this league where you look at
the nfc foreign look at you know both
sides and because there's no great team
although i look at and say
oh there's probably five or six teams
that i could see representing uh
you know the nfc in the super bowl
i just wonder if it's
we're not gonna necessarily be great by
the end of the year but which team can
put together the best
three or four game run
at playoff time put it all together
that's the team that's going to
represent either side in the super bowl
i don't think it's going to be oh this
team
is the team going in the playoffs that's
dominant
it's going to be hey this team could win
or that team could win and who puts that
that run together
um and that might be who we uh we end up
seeing in the super bowl match so it's
really it's it's it's crazy how you know
we always talk about teams that finish
hot or are are important to see but
this is it right like that's the story
of 2021 the longest regular season we've
ever seen
might actually play out with who
finishes hot
based on whatever their best start
whoever started best needs to finish hot
because it doesn't matter how you
started is that basically what we're
saying here that's how that's how i see
it and maybe it's more because
it looks like every team is is flawed
and so when your team is flawed meaning
that you have ways in which you can lose
or you know you're not going to win
every game as we've seen i mean every
top five seats in the nfc all have lost
over the last two weeks
so when that's the case um
i i think it's kind of now going okay
since we have flaws we've gotta get the
right matchups we gotta you know play
good at the right moment um as opposed
to thinking we're going to
fix all of our issues over the never
next seven weeks and just be a great
football team across the board kurt
warner here on the rich eisen show fresh
off of calling the monday night football
niners win
and then you you've got teams that could
be four and five five and four
or six and four that are in the midst of
great runs that that can't be stopped so
i want to just hit start that with the
san francisco 49ers first and
i mean that was it that that's that's
the performance we're waiting to see
from last night kirk that's it right
there yeah that's exactly right and you
know this is the team that i think most
people thought we would see
all year long the pieces were there they
were healthy again they had a chance to
be that kind of team
and you're right i mean
i didn't see many flaws they ran the
football as you expected jimmy g played
as well as he can play
defense played huge even though i'd like
to see a little bit more from their
front four uh you know earlier in the
game but thought they played really well
in the secondary and you looked at that
team and you go well that team could
beat anybody
in the league
and you know it's hard to believe that
you know we've seen them kind of sputter
through the year and they're really just
one game back
from that uh that seventh playoff spot
so there is so much football to be
played
uh right now that you know teams that
that we put a fork in the other uh the
other week on game day morning
i i don't know if you can put a fork in
anybody really or maybe just a few teams
because
you know minnesota they win a couple
games
they're in the i mean it's just you just
look around the league and i just think
there's going to be a lot of movements
um within divisions and within
conferences over the the rest of the
season how about cam with the panthers
you can already see the panthers have
some sort of new wind at their at their
back that they didn't think was possible
this year you could just see that feel
it you know the fans are traveling to
arizona they went nuts they they're
going nuts when cam's just driving
around town you know like you could feel
that and they're five and five
exactly and the thing is they've got a
really good defense i think their
defense or you know they lost some games
here because their offense
was sputtering and turning the football
over and putting their defense in that
spot
and so now i look at this team with
christian mccaffrey and cam and again
nobody really knows what cam's going to
be
on the whole
you know based off of what we've seen
the last couple years through the
injuries and and in new england and all
that but
i know he can still be a part of a
quality run game and he can give you an
advantage there and so i look at this
carolina team and say if they can
develop
you know a run game similar to what new
england did
last year with the weapons they have on
the outside if cam can be solid um throw
in the football without turning the
football over
i do think this could be a team that
pushes for the playoffs and could be a
dangerous team
uh because
they're solid on both sides when they're
not turning the football over and we saw
that early in the year so i do think the
energy of cam uh you know the dynamic
play of cam in certain situations
can make this a really interesting team
um you know moving forward and as you
said i mean tampa after you know losing
a couple in the last three i mean you
know there's by no means running away
with this division where somebody
couldn't challenge him and they've got
their their last two of their last three
games for both teams it's the home and
home
bucks and panthers those are the last
three weeks it's a home and home for
uh for both of those teams it's gonna be
wild i mean that they could come down to
the last three weeks of the season kurt
warner here on the rich eisen show uh
last couple for you kurt before i let
you on on your tuesday uh let's talk
about two six and four teams with a with
a head of steam starting with the
patriots who kick off week 11 in atlanta
and if the atlanta team that showed up
in dallas shows up at home against this
patriots team the way that new england's
playing it's going to be another boat
race loss
for atlanta i said yesterday kurt and
i'm you're the perfect person to ask and
then of course scoff
um that
uh
that the patriots the way that
that mac jones is looking right now
he looks a lot like brady
when brady was first operating this
offense in that season that wound up in
the super bowl against you i wonder what
you're seeing out of mack jones
well i mean if you're gonna go back to
that season
i would say you're getting more from mac
jones than you got from tom brady um
you know but but you're right the team
is built on a really really good defense
very flexible defense a lot of guys that
can do a lot of different things
defensively which has really kind of
been what bill belichick likes is to be
able to interchange guys and give a
bunch of different looks so they're
playing great they're running the
football really really well uh with a
bunch of different guys damien harris
was playing great
and then you have stevenson who goes for
over 100 yards the other day against the
browns so they're running the football
really well and then you have mac jones
who is playing ahead of his years he's a
guy that has shown that he can make big
throws for you
more importantly he's a guy that shows
you he can make the right play
most of the time which you get a
quarterback that can make the right play
most of the time and you're going to be
in the mix for the playoffs and he just
is going to get better and better and is
doing more and more for this team and
you couple that with the rest of
the units and again i i'm still
reserving myself to say i'm not sure
they can go four games and beat the best
teams in the league quite yet
but
they are a team nobody wants to face
they are a team that i believe can knock
off anybody
in the league and so
if they get into the playoffs which i
believe they will the way they're
playing right now nobody's going to want
to see him nobody's going to want to
face him and then we'll get a chance to
see this young quarterback if he can
take that next step and really compete
with the best in the league and uh you
know and push for a possible afc
championship i mean the one thing we
haven't seen from him yet is the brady
comeback with two minutes to go right
down we're just two two timeouts left
got to go the length of the field got to
get it got to go got to get some points
if not a touchdown we have yet to see
that out of mack jones to finally i
guess christen him in that way
but um
just i'll pull on this string even
though i do want to talk about you
the chiefs with you before i let you go
uh what do you mean he's doing more than
brady in that first year what do you
mean by that well i mean brady was
really a placeholder that first year you
know like even in the super bowl brady
threw for 150 yards and in that game
where they beat us it was really built
on defense and running the football uh
mack is
you know he's not in that same mode yes
they're running the football and they're
running the football well but they're
they're putting a lot on his shoulders
and they're asking him to make plays and
he's you know maybe where he really
separates himself more than
than tom but but a lot of quarterbacks
right now is what he's doing in the red
zone
some of the tight throws the way he's
able to manipulate defenses and
understand what he's seeing
at this stage in his career uh you know
to me it's better than a lot of guys in
the league but better than what tom
brady was
at this point in time and so he's making
some really big time decisions and
throws and reads in the red zone um that
really
have impressed me early in his career
and let's finish up with the chiefs kurt
you you and kevin harland did the monday
night football game in arrowhead when
they beat the giants that started a
three-game win streak
that uh culminating right now if not
continuing with uh that big win in vegas
on sunday night where we saw the chiefs
arrive in 2021 for the first time as we
expect even though and they overcame a
turnover as opposed to having it
uh drag them down a one on on special
teams are the chiefs back
um yeah again not ready to say they're
back yet um
because you know it's really just been
one game where they've
where they've put it all together and it
looks like the chiefs um that we
expected um
but but i think they're gonna round into
form you know definitely better than we
saw earlier in the year and we've seen
their defense do this for a couple years
where they couldn't stop anybody and as
the season goes on they start to figure
it out a little bit
uh their defense is playing better uh
defenses is creating some pressure and
creating some turnovers um and you know
we know that their offense
i mean it's like a sleeping giant we
know it's there you know we know they've
got the pieces we know that their
quarterback is is special and so it's
just a matter of
kind of settling back in i really felt
early in the year that patrick was
trying to do too much you know he was
getting impatient in the pocket and
moving around and wanting to make those
special off schedule throws as opposed
to just
making the plays that are there to be
made which is what's always made him
special and then adding the extra when
he had to really felt like he was
pressing you know from from last year in
the super bowl uh to say i gotta do more
i gotta you know i gotta be better if
we're going to win a championship and i
think what we saw the other night was
him playing more on schedule
playing more comfortable in the pocket
and when he does that and when the guys
on the outside are winning that's what
you get you get 40 burgers every time
out and so not ready to say that they're
there because it was one really solid
game whereas
most of this season has been kind of a
hodgepodge of stuff thrown together good
bad ugly
but
i know it's there and i without a doubt
they're going to get better as the
season goes along it's can they get back
to that form that we've seen for the
last couple years and then again maybe
back to our original point which is i
don't know if they have to be that team
like i mean you know you look at the afc
and yeah the titans are playing well but
i'm not sure the titans scare me to say
like oh this is a dominant team if you
don't play well you can't beat the
titans buffalo the same way is you know
they've been up and down and got beat by
the jags a couple weeks ago and you're
just saying they're not a team that i i
go oh my gosh you better bring your a
game or or you can't knock them off i
don't know if there's that team in the
afc so the chiefs may not have to be
quite as dynamic as they've been in the
past to win the afc if uh especially if
patrick mahomes gets hot
yeah i mean we're nine days away kurt
from our uh annual nfl game day morning
thanksgiving day show where we're able
to mulligan our super bowl picks i had
uh chiefs versus the bucks and um on
this show i reversed the chiefs to the
titans
i don't know if i'm gonna choose the
next nine days to maybe stick with it
you know where are you leaning on your
super bowl pick what do you think where
are
you
the same way i went uh i went the same
way with the bucks
and the chiefs
um what are you thinking and uh yeah i'm
not i'm not sure what i'm thinking i
forgot all about
that right here
i know you've got a lot going on you and
you and brenda are doing the junket
press junket for american underdog
you're flying all over the country to
see your son too let's see your kids
play so think about i'm gonna take all
nine days to think about it yeah because
that's coming again that's the crazy
thing is you know you think you say okay
if i'm gonna change it who am i changing
it to like in the nfc you know who am i
changing it to that i feel more
confident in
than the bucks you know making that run
and i feel kind of the same way in the
afc is that you're right titans are
playing better than the chiefs are
but i'm still not fully confident to say
man what i saw with the chiefs on sunday
that they're not going to be that team
when it's all said and done but you know
me i'm probably going to flip-flop
somewhere i'm gonna i'm gonna change my
pick i mean i change it every time i get
an opportunity because you know the
league is like that and uh you know so
not sure where i would go right now um
but i think the bucks and chiefs are are
good bets still
um but you know you mix in buffalo and
tennessee and maybe the cardinals in
there uh the packers um you know i think
all those teams could could end up you
know showing up in the super bowl kurt
you're the best thanks for the call
enjoy your uh tuesday and i will see you
uh on game day morning next week thanks
everybody talk to you soon that's my
hall of fame friend and hall of fame
person kurt warner right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here